[Music]
rum raisin hmm Helly they give a [ __ ]
about their KitKat's packaging so lovely
but it's so deceiving I don't know what
I'm about to eat definitely smells very
strongly of rum oh hell yes
ooh tastes a lot like Captain Morgan in
a KitKat tastes like there's a shot of
rum in this cake batter and it's just
I'm just gonna be sober I can drive home
after a whole box of it
I can keto ogon blend which means citrus
goldenblood flavor have a break have a
kicked that but this funny is like not
quite giving a break ooh that smells
like that's the dress this is delicious
it kind of tastes like a creamsicle
first you get some orange then it's very
lemony misses in your everyday misses
like and then you're like is that why my
leg Thanks when you want to spice things
up a little bit you get this is like
that you're introducing role playing
into the bedroom kind of kick-ass hot
Japanese chili flavor hot Japanese chili
flavor maybe it's just for sexy Japanese
people this box looks very dangerous
this is just straight-up dark chocolate
what does the pepper mean oh wait oh oh
yeah
you found it this is the best KitKat
ever let's get a little spicy now give
it like a minute it's like a minute
chocolate it's like a hint or spice but
it's a perfect interspace know you think
it's dark chocolate and then BAM I want
to hug the guy who's better this pile of
purple rope flavored whoa it's purple
sweet potato flavor from the box it
looks like a kit kat from like a
nightmare that Willy Wonka
it doesn't taste like anything
oh it's taro purple sweet potato right
yeah doesn't taste like flowers doesn't
taste like potatoes nothing about this
tastes like potato or purple if you like
taro your hope you'll like this it's you
don't and you're just like the bus it's
big leaf sweet and tastes kind of like
ice cream that's good
what what what are you
oh come on this is so ridiculous why do
you have to heat up candy this looks
like duck poop it tastes like maple
syrup
it's like cinnamon nice it smells like a
candle it's like you walk into your
grandma's house and this is the smell
she's just been and Kit Kats
it is like creme brulee I mean it's
delicious but like why why no one's
gonna be heating up a kick out and so he
goes right now no one in America is
gonna be eaten epic ticket it's probably
the most delicious cake I've ever had to
be honest it's delicious but like they
take their cake cuts oh god no seriously
over there I think there's something in
about knowing your place in the world
and a KitKat you should not try and
elevate itself to a baked pastry